Are you thinking of knitting
a sweater on your knitting machine?
Stop.
Before you start, there are a few
things that you need to know.
If you've just bought a knitting machine
and you're dreaming of making your
first sweater, you're not alone.
But here's the thing.
Knitting a sweater on your machine isn't
as simple as just threading up
some yarn and getting started.
A lot of knitters jump right into big
projects like sweaters,
only to run into frustration
when things don't go as planned.
Maybe the fit is off,
or the yarn isn't behaving the way you
expected, or your machine feels
like it has a mind of its own.
Does that sound familiar?
You're not alone.
This is one of the most common struggles
I hear from knitters every day.
The truth is, knitting a great sweater
takes more than just
a machine and some yarn.
It takes planning, skills, and practice.
A sweater isn't just It's
another small project.
It's a mix of design, fit, and finishing
techniques that all need to work together.
If one piece is off, the whole
sweater can be really disappointing.
But here's the good news: no matter what
your experience level, success is
absolutely within your reach.
If you're feeling overwhelmed about
where to start, I've got you covered.
I've put together a free sweater planning
worksheet to help you think through your
design, yarn, and the skills you'll need.
Grab it now, just click the link below
and start your sweater
journey with confidence.
In this video series,
we're breaking it all down step by step,
from planning and choosing the right
pattern to mastering the key techniques
that you need
and avoiding common mistakes.
I'll walk you through know.
By the end, you'll have the confidence
and the skills to knit
a sweater you'll love to wear.
So whether you're brand new to machine
knitting or have been at it for a while,
this series is for you.